the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so we're gonna do a basic
three-point lighting setup this is one
of the kits I use this is a compact one
case lighting kit as I call it it's got
a few we're gonna go over what's in it
here here's one very important item in
the kit it has everything to do with
lighting transparent microbubble powder
sometimes you your subject will be a
little too shiny under the lights and
this transparent base will get rid of
the shine without changing the color of
their complexion and if you use the
transparent powder always use an a brand
new makeup pad or wedge because you
don't want to cause problems but that's
an essential item in the kit this is a
grid which we'll see in a moment we'll
pull that out a couple of extension
cords very useful items to have this is
the Lowell Refah what's really nice
about the reefa is that it's a very
compact soft light that folds up like an
umbrella and very easy to pop open
and it opens up like that and we will
revisit this in a moment
extension cords and if my extension cord
doesn't have multiple taps on the end I
always attach a cube tap because you
never know when you're gonna need to
plug in something else this is the
Lowell tota basic open face light comes
with a safety screen and you should
always use it with the screen quartz
halogen lamps when they shatter you
don't want hot glass anywhere near
living things so if you use the Lowell
total light you definitely want to make
sure that the safety screen is always on
it the new generation V light
encapsulate s-- the lamp inside of a
glass case for safety but that's the
older style here's a fernell instrument
there's your scalloped glass lens and
all for now instruments have a flood to
the right spot to the left flood the
cleanest most even light source comes in
flood mode and we'll see how that floods
and spots in a moment barn doors are
usually included and we'll put these on
D for now and the barn doors are used
for controlling the spill and they get
their name because they seem to look
like barn doors of course I've never
seen a barn that shaped round like that
but usually travel with a second
extension cord this one's green because
I bought it at 75% off at an after
Christmas sale that's the best time to
buy extension cords for some reason the
green ones become much cheaper than the
other colored ones the day after
Christmas
then Frodo makes a variety of light
stance
these are nice lightweight aluminum
stands which are very handy for when
you're traveling and we will set those
up in a moment when you set up the
stands you should always make sure that
the bottoms are as wide out as they go
for maximum stability
and here's the umbrella that goes with
the total light which we will be using
today as well so this attaches the total
light has an accessory as an accessory
connection thing that's a technical term
think that it attaches to the light and
that gives us a nice soft light which
we'll see in a moment here's the quarter
blue gel I was talking about so for
example if I hold this over the lens and
we set the white balance we can actually
increase this sort of the warmth of the
of the world so we can fool the white
balance circuit into thinking that the
world is more blue and then we pull it
pull it away so this eighth blue gel is
very handy dandy thing to have also in
the kit we have the Siemens stars for
focusing for precise focusing these are
really easy to focus on and this is also
a gray card and on the opposite side a
white card for balancing you never know
when you might have trouble finding a
nain 1/2 by 11 piece of white paper so I
always keep the white card in the kit as
well we talked about gloves these will
keep you from burning your hands and
very important always have a set of
spare lamps lamps have a tendency to
burn out in the most inopportune moment
so I always keep spare lamps in a nice
little cushion box sometimes when you're
shooting outdoors all you need is a
reflector to kind of fill in the shadows
this wonderful device called the Flex
fill which opens up like this comes they
come in different varieties I like the
matte silver on one side and the matte
white on the other so if we need to fill
in the shadows
with a very very kind of spunky light or
a very very subtle light we have those
two sides you store them away by giving
them a little twist and throwing them
back into the case you can get
accessories that will hold the Flex vil
and you can attach it to a light stand I
have one of those in my larger kit but
that usually doesn't travel in the
smaller kit and sometimes I want to
color I want to color the light I keep a
little file here with a variety of color
gels blues for cooling things off orange
and pink gels for warming things up
actually put these in the order of the
rainbow
and of course and I also have a bunch of
I keep the orange and the blues for
warming up and cooling lights in their
own set along with some diffusion so if
I want to diffuse the light for example
this is standard 216 or full diffusion
you put this over light and it'll really
soften it so we're gonna look at some
diffusion today and this is actually a
half blue gel that is actually
specifically cut for use with the reef a
light the blue gel is used to bring the
warm tungsten light of the reef closer
to daylight I use the half blue instead
of the full blue because the full blue
cuts the light way too much kind of like
is it two or two-and-a-half stops the
full blue cuts the light a little too
much the half blue still gives me some
some light intensity to work with so
often I will split the difference in the
white balance so keep one of I keep one
of these specifically cut and sized for
the reef alight so it can be attached
really quickly
now it's very important the reef alight
has a bear incandescent lamp it's very
important that you you don't touch the
lamp you don't want to get finger oils
on it they can cause the the fingerprint
area to be at a different temperature
than the rest of the lamp and the glass
could crack so you want to be very
careful never operate the reefa light
without the diffusion cover so here's
the low Rifa and there is an optional
accessory the offset arm which is really
important if you're mounting this on a
relatively lightweight stand it's going
to tip over really easily but with the
offset arm the weight is balanced evenly
on a light stand so this offset arm is a
pretty important accessory never use the
light without the diffusion cover
because this not only is providing the
diffused light but it's also covering up
the quartz halogen lamp because you
never want to have a bear lamp in front
of your talent and this kind of attaches
with Velcro
there we go so there is our soft light
it comes with a short cord and so we
need the comes with its own little
extension cord with a standard IEC
connector and there is our soft key is
that could you plug that into the power
strip
all right so now we have a lovely soft
light which we'll use as our key so
Chrissy you're ready for your interview
I am alright so we're going to interview
Chris today and here is Zach is going to
be operating camera and we're gonna
start with our wreath alight as our key
light on Chris glasses on or off David
glasses on okay it gives us more fun to
work with right so now right now we're
using the Rifa as our key and we have a
lot of overhead lights in this classroom
I'm going to turn off the ambient light
for now so this is a single key light no
Phil no background light no backlight
pretty dramatic what we would call a
very high lighting ratio probably
something worthy of film noir it may or
may not be appropriate for our piece but
that is our starting point we typically
set our key light our primary light
source and determine what we wanted to
do notice how we get a very different
quality if I raise the key light a
little bit and if I move it off to the
side versus moving it more towards the
front
this is a little more glamorous now
there's no dramatic shadow it's almost
like an overhead towards the front key
light so notice how as we bring it to
the side and bring it down a little bit
we have a much more dramatic arrangement
so now what we want to do is we want to
fill the shadows that are being created
by the key light and maybe bring a
backlight or a background light into the
picture
for the for the fill light I think we'll
use our total light with an umbrella
what's handy about all these Lowell ices
they use the same connector same cable
style it's nice that uh it's nice that
all the lowlights have pretty much the
same connector and wiring system they're
interchangeable and they wrapped easily
into a case and can be stored very
portably because the cords separate out
so we're gonna use this toda as our fill
and notice what's going on here that now
our situation is a little less dramatic
and as I bring as I bring the fill light
in I'm reducing the contrast ratio so
when we talk about contrast ratio we're
talking about the ratio between the fill
light and key the fill and key together
and just the fill so notice that in this
case the fill and the key are very
similar in intensity they're kind of the
ratio is almost one-to-one might be
closer to wanted to so as I bring my key
sorry as I bring my fill light back I'm
increasing the lighting ratio and
providing a more dramatic experience I'm
providing a more dramatic lighting
situation for the subject now since this
is you might split the difference there
and go with something like that how does
that look Zack alright so now we have a
we have a choice we can we can give
Chris a backlight for a more dramatic
theatrical look or we can simply use our
third light source as a background light
but I think what we'll do now is let's
see what a backlight does for Chris so
we're going to use this 300 watt for now
as a backlight on Chris we're going to
set it up over here
sometimes I do it opposite the key a lot
of times it depends on my mood what
seems to make sense for the particular
scene in question
notice that we're getting like directly
into the camera you can see you're
getting flares Jared so we're getting
flares in probably both camera lenses
both cameras notice how by adjusting the
barn doors I can reduce that lens flare
so what's nice about it for now
instrument is the barn doors actually
work because the light beams are sort of
so straight they're easy to control so
what we've done here is we've provided a
backlight on Chris and we've used the
barn doors to reduce the spill directly
into the camera lens to avoid that flare
that you saw now this is looking kind of
dramatic wouldn't you say now we've got
these great little things called scrims
which we can pop into our fernell
instrument and reduce the intensity
scrim is just a wire screen that fits in
front of the lamp and cuts out literally
just cuts down how much light comes out
of it so notice I have brought down the
intensity of the backlight without
having to move it and change its
position and quality I've just used the
scrims to reduce the intensity so that's
another most Fornell instruments have
slots for single or double scrims a
double scrim basically cuts the light
one stop cuts it in half or you can cut
it less with a single scrim the other
nice thing about a scrim ii-if just
those are halves
so these are this also allows you to
Cudi this sort of the bottom part or the
top part you can actually adjust where
the scrim goes in the light and have
some control over which part up or down
side left or right is cut
yeah so there's single and doubles and
there's halves which are physically half
so sometimes you want half the beam to
be brighter than the other half now
sometimes I like my back lights to be a
slightly different color than my key
lights so I'm gonna put a blue gel
attaching it to the barn doors with
clothes pins also known as c-47s and
notice what's going on now is we've
cooled off a little bit and I might
whatever do remove those scrims now by
the way scrims can get very hot you
don't want to pull them out with your
bare hands sometimes people will take a
pair of clothes pins and hook it up
backwards and you end up with what's
called a scrim polar so notice now that
my back light is a little bluish and
it's a little intense we we might want
to tweak this further but for the sake
of this demo how are the glasses looking
another issue that we deal with is
reflections and glasses so there's
several things we can do about
reflections and glasses one thing we can
do is we can move the position of our
key crossing all right sometimes that
can help we have a tricky situation here
with both the fill and the key but
notice now we've reduced we've
eliminated that second reflection we do
have we still have a little bit of
reflection in the glasses but as Chris
talks and his moves this head a little
bit you want to watch out you know some
people simply say take your glasses off
I like to do a little bit of extra work
and ask people do you normally wear
glasses or not
if they take them off because they'd
only wear them some of the times fine if
they usually wear their glasses I'll
spend a little extra time tweaking the
lights and get it to look nice so that
I'm photographing people the way they
normally appear sometimes changing the
position by tilting the the the legs up
or down a little bit you know sometimes
a little bit of adjustment can help with
the reflection and glasses it's a little
tricky but it can work so this is a
pretty simple straightforward
three-point he fell back we could have
added some accent lights for details in
the background we could have added a
background light to lighter background
but we're just gonna keep it simple for
the sake of this demo so notice what
happens now so here's our back light
here's our fill here's our key light
we'll fill in the shadows with our fill
light and we'll provide a little bit of
drama or theatrical essence with our
backlight and give a little bit of
separation between foreground and
background one more thing the thing
about soft lights is they spill a lot so
notice how our key is spilling all over
the background there's one more
accessory that I carry in the light kit
along with the soft light and that's
called a grid and what this grid will do
is it will reduce the spill of the light
and it's available in different size
grids for different angles of allowing
different beat it's available in
different size grids providing different
amounts of spill
reduction
so now with the grid using the grid in
our key you will notice it does reduce
the intensity of the key light a bit
however notice and it might be hard to
see from this camera but we've
dramatically reduced the amount of spill
in the background we've eliminated the
background spill and the light is
primarily on the subject and since the
intensity of our key came down because
the grid does reduce the intensity of
the light a bit I might want to pull my
fill light back a little bit so now we
have a somewhat dramatic interview set
up we're still getting a little bit of
reflection with the glasses that's
something that we would need to tweak
one more thing I might do in a situation
like this but we're gonna skip it for
brevity is I might add an additional
light unit in order to provide some
definition in the background one last
thing
by the way instead of using instead of
using a fill light I could have used the
Flex Vil so notice how here grabbing
some of the light from the key light I
can actually use the silver side of the
Flex fill to fill in the shadows
though sometimes in an interview setup
it might be better to have a light unit
farther away from the subject than the
Flex Vil
but the Flex fill is kind of handy and
it doesn't have to be plugged into the
wall all right one last thing I want to
show is a scrim puller so for now
instruments usually allow you to pop in
scrims
so that you can adjust the intensity of
the light once it's in place because the
scrims are metal they get really hot so
if you rear if you reassemble a pair of
clothes pins kind of with the clips
backwards you can actually create what's
called a scrim puller and you want to
use those for popping out the scrims
because they can get really hot and you
don't want to burn your fingers so what
we've done here is a pretty traditional
straightforward three-point lighting
setup for an interview and I just wanted
to make a couple of points about what
other things to think about if this were
in fact an interview so david has set me
up here I'm the interview subject he's
the interviewer presumably in a
traditional interview situation I would
be looking just off-camera either to the
left or the right and what we have set
up here with the main on this side is
essentially probably something that
would favor me looking to the left of
the camera so David if you stand where
the interview row would be you know and
I'm talking to you here you see that I'm
just looking a little bit off-camera
maybe I'm looking here this is the side
that is the main side of the lighting
it's more brightly lit and then the
other thing would be thinking about
framing in relation to the lighting I
don't know what kind of frame you have
there since I'm not the director but you
might want to think about whether this
kind of lighting and this kind of frame
works well in both a fairly close shot
depending on what your the style you're
going for in a wider shot because you
may want to vary the the frame size
during the course of the interview when
when David asked me the
emotional question about my childhood
and your you know this is the sixty
minutes interview you'll be much tighter
zoom in for that perfect little teardrop
exactly yes the teardrop quivering on
the just the edge of the little did we
know that I there was a cut and a makeup
person put that there with an eyedropper
yes the when I was scared by a video
camera at age four and it right it
changed the course of my life but but
anyway I just so I just wanted to point
that out that this could be an actual
live interview situation and there would
be things that we would be thinking
about both in terms of framing and
position of the subject and the lighting
impacts that right another thing I'd
like another thing I'd like to add to
that is I typically do not do all of
this set up with the interview subject
standing end yes so typically typically
typically I work in a two-person team
and the person doing the interview will
hang out with the interview subject and
kind of chat with them and kind of warm
things up and do that away from all the
technical setup and I will do the
technical setup and then only do the
very last minute tweaking and
adjustments with the subject sitting
under the lights because it could take
you know thirty minutes to set
everything up really carefully sound
lighting etc and you know you don't want
to put people through that you know I
mean we we have a separate class on
interview techniques and things to think
about when doing an interview but the
the comfort and relaxed state of your
subject is obviously really really
crucial and putting them through what I
just went through you know I'm patient
because I don't mind being a guinea pig
here but putting them through that is
not a good way to begin a relationship
when you're gonna be asking them
questions similarly another point I
wanted to make about the the lighting is
you want to obviously make things look
good and put the lights where they need
to be in order to get a good image and
look that you that works for you but you
also want to think about the comfort of
your subject so again having something
too glaring directly in their eyes a
very powerful light can be a problem and
raising the light a little bit higher so
that it's not as see right there that
makes a huge difference right in fact
usually light
and that you know that's actually
another reason why I prefer the psy.d
light it's not just about being dramatic
and and kind of following in the
Rembrandt tradition but a lot of it is
also driven by not having the light
glare directly into the Sun so now if
I'm talking to David and back in the
interviewer position I can see him I'm
not looking into the light it's just
much more comfortable for me there's
also another thing that people often do
called comfort lights which basically
would be another small light that
actually isn't lighting me at all but is
a very low-power light that's lighting
David or lighting the background so that
I'm not just staring into this black
well with these bright lights pointing
at me I actually can see who I'm talking
to I can see the environment just a
little bit and we know we keep them very
low and very low power so that they
don't actually affect the image but it
just adds to the comfort level of the
person but yeah David also made an
extremely good and important point that
that when you're working doing an
interview of particularly if it is kind
of a sensitive subject having two people
is really really important not just to
schlep the equipment but because one
person can be sort of developing a
rapport with the interview subject while
the other person is handling all of this
stuff yeah and and it gets really really
difficult sometimes if you put somebody
through especially someone who's not
really used to doing this through this
this whole experience of the tweaking
and the and and the lighting setup and
glaring lights in their eyes and then
and you say go ready start and that that
can be a very sort of off-putting
experience yeah and one last thing is
we've done this pretty dramatic almost
theatrical set up for this particular
demo but if I was interviewing Chris
about teaching this class we would
probably find a nice window maybe facing
north or south so we don't get direct
sunlight in the middle of the interview
we'd sit by that window and some soft
light and we'd talk there and I'd
probably never pull a lighting
instrument out of the kit so start with
mother nature see if the natural light
works for you and if not you can always
work artificially and remember to apply
the
Constable's that we've been talking
about both in the the lecture part and
in this demo to non lighting instrument
situations a little bit of backlight
adds a lot of definition of well there
are other ways to get backlight than
setting up a light maybe we should do
one last setup sure using the natural
lights available in this room the camera
currently is not correctly white balance
that's why everything looks orange and
we're going to do a white balance for
you so here's a white card
all right so here let's white balance
the taking camera Zack is going to white
balance the semi a 1p menu and then
white balance and then there's the one
push
all right so now this is what Chris
looks like with a technically correct
white bounce so now let's do that again
Chris have you could hold up the white
card let's do that again and hold an
eighth blue filter over the lens we're
going to fool the camera into thinking
there's more blue in the world now we're
going to do the 1 push white balance
got it and now we pull away the blue and
Chris looks a little warmer teeny bit
warmer
just a tad it's like adding a little bit
of basil to your spaghetti sauce
slightly more flavorful now this is
beautiful window light we're not getting
direct sun shining into the room so it's
all beautiful soft skylight and from
this camera angle that zach is shooting
from looks reasonably good it's a bit
dramatic because remember that inverse
square law kind of hard to get away from
it the light falls off pretty quickly
but at this angle Chris if you look at
me from this angle we're getting a
pretty nice wrap around his face clearly
we have a bright side and a darker side
of the face but it looks very natural
it's kind of hard to beat really nice
Vermeer like soft window light and of
course just as you can change the light
or the position of the light and the
other setup here you could change the
position of the subject so you could
have me move and if you could just pan
with me you move this way if I move
crisp as a rim the window here it gets
flatter I'm right lit from the front so
you notice how flat that is
but now Chris if you move right here and
look straight into the camera and look
over here now see how dramatic that is
with a dark side and a large light side
so just now look at me look at how that
dramatically changes so in just this
small area moving the camera a little
bit
moving the subject a little bit we can
adjust the light for what works and it
ultimately depends on determining what
works for your scene exactly and if we
need fill we can you know we could bring
in the the Flex fill if necessary but
typically when I'm shooting like this I
might be so low Lobo and there's no one
to hold a reflector so if I can find a
nice position a nice soft window light
somewhere hopefully away from a lot of
noise so let's go back to the dramatic
position that maybe Zach can hold the
Flex fill and put it in
just seems like so you come away from
the window a little bit so it's nothing
more dramatic right pretty dramatic so
that's a pretty dramatic that's a pretty
intense lighting ratio but notice using
the Flex fill I can fill in the shadows
wax off wax on wax off wax off if I use
the matte white side the effect is more
subtle wax off wax off
so the Flex fill can provide you with
really nice fill light so typically when
we're working outdoors and we're going
low-tech flex fill and mother nature
cinema is light moving in time
that's your wrap up yeah
so I'll just say that we've looked at a
lot of tools today and everything from
clothes pins c-47s to Fornell lights and
and more but ultimately the the most
important tool is your eye and that's
what I was trying to get at earlier when
I talked about actually seeing what's in
the scene and making changes based on
what you're seeing your eye is an
incredible instrument it's far better
than any camera it's far more adaptable
in different lighting situations in fact
it's so good that you have to sometimes
learn to see past it and see what's
what's actually there and what a camera
would see which is not as adaptable so
it takes a lot of practice until it
eventually becomes second nature but
taking a look at the scene and then
making adjustments either to your
subject or to the light whether they be
lighting instruments or windows is
really the basic process of doing
lighting as it is the basic process of
almost any aspect of filmmaking so
thanks a lot Dave I appreciate you
coming in happy to come in fantastic and
you know your your blog kino-eye comm is
a great resource for
just lighting tips but video and media
documentary monthly documentary and I'd
like to thank Zack Rey for helping us
today and thanks again also to our
terrific cameraman Jared Rooney AK who
is living what we're just talking about
as we as we film this